Traductor: Bbo Subtitulado4
Revisor: Silvina Katz
Supongo que os sorprenderá
ver a un individuo adulto y serio,
o al menos en apariencia,
arrastrando un neumático por el escenario.
Pero imaginad lo que debían pensar
los vecinos de la Eliana, mi pueblo,
cuando me veían hacer esto mismo
a las cuatro de la madrugada.
La policía local también se sorprendía.
Lo que pasa es que ellos lo hacían
partiéndose de risa,
me conocen y la cosa quedaba ahí.
La Guardia Civil no tiene
tanto sentido del humor.
Ellos se quedaban siempre
muy serios dentro del coche
sin bajar las ventanillas, ni decir nada,
mirándome muy fijamente
de arriba abajo,
como pensando si llevarme
al cuartel o dejarme suelto.
Y no les culpo, porque ver a un señor
a las tantas de la noche,
con pintas de haberse escapado de
"Sé lo que hicisteis el último verano",
arrastrando dos ruedas,
pues sorprendería a cualquiera.
Pero es que, en los últimos años,
me he visto en la necesidad
de entrenarme
para arrastrar grandes cargas.
Y que además, puede ser más peligroso
de lo que puede parecer, porque
cuando andas por el borde de una acequia,
si se cae una rueda, detrás va la otra
y detrás va la bestia de carga.
Creedme, que me ha pasado dos veces.
Luego, además, en mi pueblo, cada vez
que aparece un neumático por ahí tirado
me llegan un montón de mensajes.
Por un lado, por si lo he perdido yo
y por otro lado,
por si me interesa quedármelo.
Si además trasladamos
este entrenamiento a la montaña,
te cruzas con gente
y siempre hay alguien
que tiene que decirte algo.
Que si has pinchado,
que si te haz dejado el coche arriba
averiado y lo estás bajando a piezas.
Gente muy ocurrente por el mundo.
Pero bueno, la cuestión
que me trae hoy aquí es la respuesta
a qué es aquello intangible
que diferencia a un espécimen como yo
de una persona, digamos, normal.
Pero, para ello, os tengo que poner
primero brevemente en antecedentes.
Desde mi más tierna infancia
me he dedicado a practicar deporte,
todo tipo de deportes.
Me ha interesado siempre
todo lo que se ha puesto delante de mí.
Crecí haciendo atletismo,
luego vino la montaña
y todos los deportes que conlleva:
alpinismo, esquí, escalada ...
La montaña se convirtió
en el centro de mi vida,
hasta que sucedió un hecho,
que sacudió los cimientos de mi existencia
tal y como la conocía en ese momento
y cambió radicalmente mi vida.
Un hecho, que primero me llamó "papi",
luego "papá"
y ya más mayor "padre"
u "organismo pluricelular progenitor".
Y os juro que esto es totalmente cierto.
Tuve que dedicarme a otros deportes,
empecé a hacer triatlón,
ciclismo, natación, carreras de montaña,
cada vez distancias más largas,
hasta que descubrí el mundo de
las carreras de ultra distancia árticas.
Que son, como su nombre indica,
carreras muy largas
de cientos de km, las hay de hasta 1600,
que se desarrollan en territorios árticos,
inhóspitos, desolados, deshabitados,
en pleno invierno a temperaturas,
a veces, por debajo de los 50 º C.
Y en los que hay que arrastrar un trineo
con lo necesario para poder sobrevivir.
En algunas de estas carreras,
el organizador, para poder inscribirte,
a través de una videoconferencia,
te hace una entrevista y te graba
reconociendo que eres consciente
de que puedes llegar a sufrir daños
o incluso morir durante la carrera.
Y te advierten que, en caso de necesidad,
pueden tardar horas e incluso días
en llegar al sitio en el que estás,
con lo cuál, habrás de resolver
todos los problemas por ti mismo.
Y a esa temperatura hay muy poco tiempo
para resolver los problemas.
En una ocasión, entré en hipotermia
intentando hacer funcionar un hornillo,
entré en pánico porque estuve
a punto de perder el conocimiento
y estuve cerca de salir corriendo,
abandonando mi equipo, para buscar ayuda.
Menos mal que respiré hondo, recapacité
y encendí rápidamente un fuego con
el que entré en calor en pocos minutos.
Y por no haber tomado la otra decisión,
hoy estoy aquí contando esta historia.
Además, ha habido gente que,
practicando estas carreras,
ha perdido dedos, manos,
e incluso las piernas.
Yo mismo, hace años, tuve congelaciones
en los dedos de una mano.
Y dicho todo esto, retomo la cuestión
que me ha traído aquí:
dar respuesta a qué diferencia
a un pájaro como yo
de la masa sensata de la humanidad.
A priori, se me ocurre
que este señor, o sea yo,
se hubiera podido dar algún golpe
de más en la cabeza en su infancia.
Pero lo rechazo por dos motivos.
Primero, porque si respondo tan rápido,
me tocaría bajarme del escenario
y, sinceramente, me apetece tener
mis diez minutos de gloria al completo.
Y el segundo y no menos importante,
porque, en mi vida de adulto
he seguido dándome golpes en la cabeza
y no parece afectar demasiado
a mi comportamiento.
Descartado este tema,
me planteo otro, que sería
pensar que yo estoy,
dicho en términos médicos,
como una cabra, como un cencerro,
como una trompeta, etc.
Respecto a esto, me vais a permitir
que os cuente otra historia.
Hace años, me encontraba entrenando
una noche, como siempre,
arrastrando mis ruedas,
bajo una impresionante luna llena
y tuve una epifanía.
Allí, bajo aquella luna llena,
casi me pongo a aullar,
me di cuenta de que yo era
la única persona cuerda del mundo.
Y que vosotros, el resto de la humanidad,
durmiendo plácidamente en vuestras camas,
erais los que estabais locos.
Llamadme lunático.
Y en este caso con fundamento.
Pero, la locura y la cordura
son dos términos muy relativos.
Y como dicen que una imagen
vale más que mil palabras,
voy a dejar que estas hablen por mí,
para intentar convenceros
de si realmente,
una persona está tan loca
por querer vivir semejantes experiencias.
Aparcado el tema
de los golpes en la cabeza
y de mi cuestionable salud mental,
pregunté a un amigo,
el cuál que me contestó
es que tal vez la diferencia
es que yo era un yonqui de lo imposible.
Puede ser.
Y a este respecto, me vais a permitir
que os cuente otra anécdota.
El Cor es el club donde me entreno
y por el que compito.
Y hace unos años,
se compartía en redes sociales,
la noticia de la próxima organización
de una carrera que consistía en correr
desde España, atravesando Europa,
cruzar el mar Báltico nadando,
atravesar Finlandia, Rusia, Siberia,
hasta el lago Baikal al norte de Mongolia.
5000 km de pura locura.
Como un poseso y desesperado me puse
a buscar información inmediatamente
preguntando a todo el mundo.
Nadie contestó y días después
me dirigí a entrenar al Cor,
donde mis compañeros me esperaban,
partiéndose de risa,
porque, de las 100 personas
que había en el grupo,
era el único que no se había dado cuenta
que la noticia era del 28 de diciembre.
Sí, reconozco que
soy un yonqui de lo imposible,
pero muchos de vosotros
también os marcáis retos, objetivos,
que no son tanto metas
como sí, caminos, proyectos,
que nos ayudan a tener motivación
para vivir y para disfrutar del día a día.
Con lo cual, puede que yo
lo haga a otra escala,
pero no considero
que sea la diferencia principal.
Descartado el golpe
en la cabeza, la salud mental
o mi adicción a los retos imposibles,
pregunté a la gente que más tiempo
lleva aguantándome, mi familia.
Mi padre lo tiene claro,
el golpe en la cabeza que me va a dar él
para que me esté quieto de una vez.
Mi hermana me respondió con otra pregunta:
"¿Y tú cuál crees que es esa diferencia?"
Es psicóloga, como habéis supuesto.
La respuesta que más me sorprendió
fue la de mi mejor amiga, mi mujer,
que a estas alturas pensaréis
que se ha ganado el cielo, varias veces,
que respondió sin pensar, inmediatamente:
"la pasión con la que vives la vida".
Llegados a este punto casi cabría pensar
que no existe esa diferencia,
si te descuidas hasta soy la persona
más normal de esta sala.
Quizá es posible que sea más consciente
que la mayoría de la gente
de lo efímero de la vida
y de que hay que vivirla
como si cada día fuera el último.
No digo que todo el mundo tenga
que ponerse a correr carreras árticas,
ni hacer alpinismo,
ni saltar en paracaídas,
ni jugar al parchís en el ala
de un avión en vuelo.
Pero sí que debemos atrevernos
a llevar a cabo nuestros sueños,
por imposibles o difíciles que parezcan.
Y procurar no dejarlos
para un futuro muy lejano
pensando que siempre podremos cumplirlos,
porque, si hay alguna diferencia
que yo he visto que sí que hay
entre yo y la mayoría de las personas,
es que donde otros
se preguntan "¿por qué?",
yo siempre me pregunto "¿por qué no?".
Muchas gracias.